Perhaps some nights you lie awake next to your partner.
Probably they're not awful.
But they are almost certainly a bit boring.
After all it's been a long time.
Sex with them is ok
but not great in every possible way.
There's something so special about undressing someone for the first time
feeling their excitement in your hands
and hearing them say rude words to you in lust.
But you don't want to give up the relationship you're already in
which is pretty good in some key ways.
Maybe you've got children or a joint home you've put a lot of work into.
You don't want to lose everything.
You just want to enjoy a few new scenarios.
At such points, like many people you think:
"What about polyamory"?
And you feel quite brave and adventurous for going this far.
Part of the problem is that polyamory sounds so plausible.
An ideal way out of our societies' collective hypocrisy around sexual desire.
Maybe you know someone from the tennis club who said to be into polyamory.
They seem normal, very sane and extremely cheerful.
There was an article in a magasine describing how polyamory is becoming fashionable in Paris
and is gaining popularity in Vancouver.
Apparently, plenty of others manage it. Why shouldn't you?
Polyamory looks like it could be, as its advocates suggest, the future of relationships in general.
And, more urgently, of yours in particular.
Like many aspects of existence, polyamory is convincing in principle.
Big, general ideas, usually are.
To take another exemple:
In principle, many people feel it would be nicer to give up on the rat-race in the city and relocate to the countryside.
It's healthier, housing costs are lower.
You'll be able to grow vegetables and reconnect with nature.
Or, to take an exemple from politics:
In principle, many people feel that direct democracy with referendum every weekend
to determine every decision sounds like a great idea.
We'd finally get the kind of government we want.
It happens in Switzerland so it's obviously possible.
And technology has made it much more possible to organise.
But the problem with principles is that they are perilously prone to leave out the details.
Which is where the problems are located
They encourage us to forget that if we move to the country, we'll be hampered in our plans to order sushi at short notice.
The neighbor's tractor will wake us up at 5:30.
Things will be surprisingly expensive.
And we'll have a terrible sense of being left out of the party.
Or when it comes to direct democracy we forget the whimsical and terrifying nature of mass public opinion
along with our own disinterest in the details of policy
and the entirely exceptional nature of Swiss society and public life.
Things are no different with polyamory.
When at certain times the general principle of polyamory strikes us as a mature and viable option for organising our sex lives
we'd be advised to hold a few details in mind:
- We should picture how challenging it can be
when at, an orgy, a partner gives us a wink as they disappear
into a softly lit bedroom with two other people.
We make a sign to join them but are politely, yet firmly
rebuffed by one of the strangers who asks gruffly who the weirdo with the strange underwear might be.
Hearing a partner orgasm at the hands of another is a complex experience.
- We may forget too that once we sign up to polyamory
it won't be entirely straightforward to locate other people who excite us deeply.
Of course, we may have offers from types we don't much fancy
except it will now be agony to explain why we don't want them.
However, even if we do find someone we favor, it may turn out their sexual tastes don't quite match our own.
They may share our love of spanking, but it could be harder or softer that we would ideally prefer.
Or, they'll love dressing as a pirate, but they might refuse to wear an eyepatch
which is a deal breaker for us.
Or, they might indeed shout obscenities but their repertoire risks being sadly unimaginative
and their accent grating.
Our partner, on the other hand
might all the while be having no trouble at all locating some pretty amazing new friends.
We had assumed we’d be in demand, but that’s not how it could turn out.
We also tend to forget how nice it is when something is fully ours.
As children, we never actually liked sharing our toys much
though borrowing them was pretty nice.
When we were five
we deeply resented if other children took the fire engine
or started a cooking game with the miniature kitchen.
A disavowed possessive streak runs quite deep in many of us.
Furthermore, we’ve got a busy life
and polyamory takes a lot of time to organise.
Our prospective partners may be busy just that night we’re free or more inclined
– exactly when we had a slot –
to hook up with that dentist who is slightly repugnant in our eyes.
Despite the freewheeling atmosphere
even in polyamory
there will be some surprisingly tricky and intractable emotions to deal with.
There will be splits, painful endings, feelings of abandonment and moments of rage.
We’ll be exposed to the inner tribulations of a great many people
rather than just those of a single well-charted spouse.
Certain partners will burst into uncontrollable sobs and talk urgently of their mothers
when all we were looking for was a rapid sexual thrill.
Others will, as we stand at the bedside with a whip or a mask, accuse us of selfishness
pretend to read a magazine and refuse to explain what’s wrong.
There’s no dispute at all that polyamory will work very well for some people
but like many alluring ideas, that doesn’t mean it will work for us.
Mostly likely, if we become polyamorous
we will once again encounter almost all of the problems we’d once known so well in monogamy
only far more often
more chaotically
and with a greater sense of violated expectation.